I've always been an outsider and really
from my earliest years I felt that I was
an outsider trying to get in trying to
forge a path trying to make my way and
ironically I ended up of course the
speaker as a member of the establishment
dermot but I certainly wasn't chosen by
the establishment and I think that also
won't be denied or argued against by
anybody it was before you became an MP
but you stayed associated with it you
joined the Mundi Club this right wing
conservative Association and you're very
frank about it in the book you talk
about that repeatedly it's a shameful
period for you personally now let's tell
people about the Monday Club and you
were inspired in part by the by the
works the speeches the thoughts of Enoch
Powell who your dad originally
introduced you to it was a great mistake
I was probably a rather insecure and
uncertain young man I hadn't quite
worked out what my future would be I was
probably a bit unsure of myself I had
been afflicted by a number of problems
in childhood I was physically a rather
unimpressive character and whether the
sort of machismo of right-wing politics
at the time particularly appealed to me
it's difficult to say I'm trying to look
back and decide and generation auntie or
a terrible mistake and not just a
mistake in the sense that in the end it
didn't serve me well but much more
importantly than that I feel to this day
terribly ashamed that as a young man I
joined what was essentially to all
intents and purposes a racist pressure
group on the fringes of the Conservative
Party and I gave encouragement and
succor to people who were promoting
racist messages some of those people
eventually you can said it's racist some
of them still in Parliament and some of
them are still on the right of the
Conservative Party are there racists in
the Conservative Party now well I'm not
thinking of anybody in particular in the
conservative parliamentary party I think
that racism is a scourge which afflicts
society as a whole I think race
relations are much better now Dermott
than they were 20 30 40 years ago but I
think it is a continuing challenge
across the political parties we've heard
quite a lot over the last year or two
about the difficulty and the real evil
of anti-semitism in the labour party I
must say I've never encountered
anti-semitism from a member of the
labour party but I have encountered
anti-semitism from some members of my
former party the Conservative Party and
there's certainly an issue of
Islamophobia in the Conservative Party
so I think really it is best for
politicians in all of the parties to
take a mature level-headed and
constructive approach to this subject to
accept that it does afflict both of the
major parties and perhaps others and
needs to be addressed David Cameron now
let me I think we've got a one of the
quotations you have about David Cameron
then are we back - are we back to class
here with David Cameron you I mean you
give us a very much a sense and many
people seem to pick it up as well during
his years as Prime Minister that he was
rather entitled and born with a silver
trolley service in his mouth sniffy
supercilious and deeply snobbish an
opportunist lightweight he didn't really
rate David Cameron no not particularly I
think he's very able I think he's very
fleet of foot he's very articulate he
can be charming now and again on big
occasions on the occasion for example of
the Bloody Sunday inquiry report he
performed with great skill and
sensitivity and dexterity but if I have
an overall criticism of him I daresay
he's got various criticisms of me it
would be that he was relentlessly
tactical rather than strategic he didn't
have an overall vision for the country
he tended just to fly by the seat of his
pants and to work on the basis that
because he was skillful on his feet and
because he had a good turn of phrase he
would hack it and famously of course he
was asked about the EU referendum he
said he would win and I think somebody
said to him why he said well I always do
Theresa May took over and you know
Theresa May perhaps given a hospital
pass the poison chalice who knows but
this is your assessment in part of
Theresa May and a lot of it was
character decent but as wooden as your
average coffee table dull as ditchwater
lacking in an ounce of small talk devoid
of any spontaneity or natural fluency
let alone charisma
disgust because she required a lot of
what she lacked there did she not for
dealing with the situation she inherited
yes I mean that is the encapsulation of
what I think of her I think she's a
decent person I think she's hard-working
I think she's public spirited I think
that all of those things are true and I
think that it is incredibly important to
be a successful political leader to have
the quality of political imagination and
I think Teresa may lacked political
imagination kavadis Johnson of course
not too long in post already won that
firm being majority in the general
election your assessment so far I mean
you know Boris Johnson quite well I know
you mentioned in the book come beating
him rather comprehensively at tennis
we'll get onto that in a moment but
there let's just get some of your
assessment at his occasional best a
possibly adequate politician he's
disproportionately preoccupied with
whatever serves the cause of advancement
for Boris Johnson in it for himself John
well he's hugely ambitious he's been
motivated throughout his career by the
absolute unyielding determination to get
to the top of the tree and he has
succeeded more over credit where it's
due he's proved so far to be a very
successful campaigner in getting office
however the real challenges having got
power what does he do with it
will he deploy statecraft not just for
his benefit but for the benefit of the
United Kingdom and there I think one has
to say the jury is out the word people
who thought that if he got a big
majority and this is an almost humongous
majority of 80 that he's got that he
would then rat on the hardline brexit
ears and in a sense pivot to a soft
brexit position and so far that hasn't
happened I mean it's very much the
opening salvos at the moment that are
being fired but in these opening
statements and speeches he's making he
seems to be signaling very clearly that
he does not want regulatory alignment
with the European Union in the name of
maximizing market access he wants to
diverge from
you and have the fullest possible escape
to forge free trade deals with the rest
of the world he can do that but if he
does that a those deals will take some
considerable time to forge and be if he
does diverge the chance of getting a
satisfactory trade deal with the
European Union seems to me somewhat
reduced and it could all have been very
different let's just focus down now on
that period after the 2017 general
election you've talked about that hung
parliament how you interpreted it how to
reason made that then Prime Minister
interpreted very differently did you see
it as your job to try to thwart the
approach that Teresa may and her
government were trying to take on brexit
or were you simply informed by the fact
that there was no overall majority in
parliament and that therefore all
parliamentarians had to have a say the
latter it absolutely wasn't my mission
to thwart her or to thwart brexit any
more than it would have been my mission
to facilitate or implement brexit that
wasn't for the speaker to do the role of
the speaker in such a situation is to
facilitate the house and what I sought
at every turn throughout my speakership
not merely in relation to brexit but in
respect of every other subject was to
let the house breathe the particular
difference post 2017 election was that
the Parliament was hung the government
had no overall majority and what from
time to time I had to say to ministers
and to the government Chief Whip was
look it's not my responsibility to
protect you from the absence of a
majority now I accept that I interpreted
the rules in some cases differently from
the way in which they've been
interpreted before there were people
Dermot who said ah what John Bercow has
done is unprecedented to which my answer
was yes the circumstances are
unprecedented I broke no rule and in
respect of the so called been Act passed
by non-government MPs to protect Britain
from a No Deal brexit unless Parliament
approved it what I was doing there was
letting the how
breathe my judgment was that I should
let the house do what the house woman
made enemies you made enemies by doing
so a particularly of those in government
and particularly one then leader of the
house Andrea led some just want to
discuss that relationship because I was
crucial between the speaker and the
leader of the house and this is just
some of how you've described what seemed
a very very difficult relationship that
she had a near pathological hatred of
you feeble and sinister and this is very
interesting and just tell us a bit about
this I took care always to be
accompanied so that there was an
independent view on what was said by
whom and when this is when you met with
her and you made sure that she had
someone on on her side
independent witnesses but why there was
no trust between us and I was advised at
one point by a senior person in
government that she was very hostile and
that she was looking to ferment trouble
for me and that individual who said this
to be in confidence and I will respect
it said to me mr. speaker can I offer
you a word of advice and I said please
do and he said if I were you I a
wouldn't rise to the bait if she tries
to wind you up and B he said if you have
meetings with her because of the
importance of it being clear
subsequently who said what to whom I
would advise you to be accompanied you
also address other allegations the
allegations of bullying made while you
while you were there by one of your
Clark's k Dems and your private
secretary
Angus Sinclair and you mystified because
she obviously denied the allegations you
know you miss divided as to why they
made them yes
frankly I was astonished when the
allegations first surfaced nearly two
years ago I think it was in March 2018
at the time nothing was said publicly by
an individual to the effect that she or
he had been bullied subsequently a
couple of months later somebody came
forward and said that he felt unfairly
treated by me I can say only two things
first of all I absolutely insist that I
have never bullied any way
anywhere at anytime secondly the
overwhelming majority of the working
relationships that I had over the years
as a member of parliament as Speaker in
the constituency office in the speaker's
office and the staff across the house
were positive and fruitful relationship
was since you've written in the book yet
as I say you address those allegations
there's two more of come out of them the
Lord is fain another senior clerk
clarinha black rod david leaky and we
interviewed david leaky last week i know
you you're aware of the allegations but
let's just remind the audience again
this is what is what the former black
rod had to say my opinion is that he
brutalized staff in the House of Commons
and elsewhere might include myself in
that and I think he brutalized is a good
word for what he did to Lourdes Liz fain
his private secretaries David Knopfler
the clerk who took over from Lourdes
Fang John Benjy the clerk who's taken
over from him as well and they have all
told me in private moments and some of
their experiences at the hands of John
Bercow my view is that he brutalized
people and it wasn't just those top
people it was people much further down
the pecking order and he tried to do it
with others politicians as well who went
into his office brutalized his the word
used three times I think this home saw
an utter rubbish from start to finish I
noticed how hesitant David Lee he was in
developing his case as though he was
choosing his words carefully total utter
rubbish
first point is that David Lee he didn't
work for me he wasn't employed by me he
wasn't an employee of the House of
Commons
he worked in and was the protocol
officer of the House of Lords he is in
absolutely no position whatsoever to
comment on my relations with my
parliamentary colleagues of which he is
completely and utterly ignorant he
doesn't know what my relations were with
my clerks
he has absolutely no intelligence on
those matters
whatsoever what we've got here is
somebody who left the house who is
thrashing around desperate to remain
relevant popping up at every turn trying
to make himself seem very important very
center stage very heart of things in the
way that I went about my work none of
those things Dermot is true absurdly
preposterous Lee he's turning up years
later a couple of years after he left
the house commenting on matters that he
can't possibly know about because he'd
already left he said something about my
relations with Andrea led some in May
2018 something that I did literally said
to her and caused her to cry he wouldn't
know he'd left three months before the
guy is a know-nothing he hasn't a
foggiest idea what he's talking about he
was deeply hostile to me he's entitled
to his views but on the matter of
bullying he suffers from the
disadvantage of being 100% wrong but a
men kill it's an agenda here because we
get now to him he was admitted it yeah
he's pontificating I mean it's very
amusing in a sense because he works in
the House of Lords he's entitled to an a
person's opinion the idea that he knows
about what was going on in the Commons
is ridiculous but he's made it very
clear that he thinks that I'm not a
suitable person to go to the laws what
we're very grateful to him if his
opinion but these are not matters for
him he would accept a peerage if given
one what's this about Jeremy Corbyn
proposing you well the leader of the
Opposition has proposed me for
membership of the upper house and I must
say that I'm very grateful to Jeremy
Corbyn for that and if somebody says or
if you're implying quizzically perhaps a
DOMA well why is it being done by the
Dean of the opposition well Jeremy
Corbyn is doing it because he thinks
it's the right thing to do the
government should have done it and the
government hasn't done it that has been
the norm for the last 240 years with
every living speaker there's no
entitlement I'm not saying it's a matter
of entitlement but it has been the norm
and I was given to understand that it
would happen senior members of the
Conservative Party gave me the
impression that it would happen they've
resolved from that and Jeremy Corbyn who
I think is very straight in these things
said well do you want the opposition to
propose you because we think you should
go to the House of Lords so I said yes
please do if you
today so and that's what they've done